so I came across a few things in the
last couple of days that I wanted to
mention the fold into this topic here
one was a recent survey in pew which
revealed that Americans are more divided
now than ever before according to the
survey and we're divided in terms of you
know not just the number of issues that
we disagree about which is basically
every issue but also the severity the
depth of those divisions and then second
there was an article in The Washington
Post a few weeks ago which cites a
different survey and also argues that
the so-called value divide between
Republicans and Democrats is getting
wider and wider and wider now I agree
with those surveys I think it's kind of
self-evident
that this is a situation
it appears to me that we have as a
country we have nothing in common
anymore
we have no shared value we have no
shared goal we have no shared sense of
purpose no shared sense of tradition or
identity nothing nothing
about this a few months ago about our
lack of shared values and our shared
identity and a lot of people and I know
as I say this now you're probably
thinking the same thing a lot of people
told me they said well we do have shared
values and and and those values are
freedom and equality Americans love
freedom and equality what are you
talking about
that's what we all have in common we're
a free country okay first of all we are
not a free country
we're not I hate to break it to you
um and second
we're only united by freedom and
equality in the sense that we all like
those words okay we all like to use the
words freedom and equality but we do not
all actually value freedom and equality
okay if you look at what we consider
those words to mean and how we think
they should be applied you'll find that
I have you know my definition of freedom
and equality is about is similar to my
neighbors as it would be to someone in
North Korea's it's about the same
you're not gonna find very many people
on earth who profess to despise freedom
and equality in principle but you will
find a lot of people who despise it in
practice and a lot of those people live
in this country and some of them work
for our government unfortunately now
remember our our wonderful nation under
God our wonderful free nation our nation
of freedom legally exterminates a
million children a year
we have killed 60 million human beings
since roe v-- wade 60 million
so that's freedom and equality except
for the 60 million we've killed
I know it upsets people when I say this
but no we are not a free country how
dare you how dare you say anything about
a free country when we've killed 60
million babies
honestly how dare any of us babble on
about our freedoms in a situation like
that
this is the worst human rights atrocity
in the history of mankind
and we are responsible for it as
Americans
while we continue to babble about our
freedom
I can just imagine two people in a car
you know talking about oh it's so great
to be free in America as they drive by
an abortion clinic
but it doesn't end there of course I
mean that's just one example
um our free and equal country also
happens to be one where Christian
business owners as of right now
Supreme Court's gonna rule on this but
as of right now they can be forced to
participate in gay wedding ceremonies
against their will
sixty percent of Americans agree that
they ought to be forced that they ought
not to have freedom of religion six
percent of Americans support some
version of socialized medicine over half
of all Americans think that their fellow
citizens should be forced to fund the
abortion industry and we are forced to
fund it all of us a majority of
Americans believe that businesses should
be forced to provide contraception to
their employees and the situation gets
even worse when you look at the young at
the younger generations that is the
generation the generation that's gonna
you know that that's taking over the
country 40 percent of Millennials think
that we should limit speech that's
offensive to minorities over half of
adults in their 20s don't believe in
free market capitalism over 30% are
avowed socialist 50 percent of
Millennials would give up their right to
vote if only their if only their student
loans would be forgiven so get a hundred
random Americans into a room and you
won't find that even half of them
actually care about freedom
or they care about a freedom that
doesn't include the unborn Christians
business owners taxpayers so we don't
share
that principle not in any meaningful way
what do we share
Americans used to be united by their
common belief in a Creator God from whom
all rights originate not anymore
America today is home to a record number
of atheists a record number of empty or
emptying churches even Americans who
call themselves Christians which is a
record of record low number of course
can't come to an agreement about what
being a Christian means many attend
churches that have rainbow flags hanging
from them where they hear about a God
who who loves gay marriage and abortion
that is many Christians are not actually
Christian so we don't have that what
else do we have
I've heard some people say Americans
value family we all love our families
and we love family we're all you know
we're pro-family
the delusions of some people's it's
pretty incredible and I'm almost envious
of it
how can we say that we all veil value
family
when we live in a country where the
average family consists of three people
a record low number of
of women have have no kids at all
or a record number of women have no kids
at all I should say divorce is rampant
fatherless homes are endemic in some
communities the numbers as high as 70 or
80%
record numbers of young people are
putting off marriage or plan to never
get married at all record numbers of
young people say they never want to have
kids at all
most Americans are saving you know
having kids for a point when they cannot
physically even conceive kids anymore
because they care more about amassing
physical wealth than going on vacations
and everything so family no that's
that's for a great many Americans family
is not even a top three of their list of
priorities
so what else do we have them language we
don't even have language anymore we
don't even share a language so what's
left
nothing of substance I mean we have
physical proximity we all share we you
know we share zip codes with each other
we share area codes with each other
beyond that we have our I'll tell you
that the one thing that we really do all
have in common the one thing that binds
us is our vices
we all love to buy things
we all love to go out on Black Friday
and just accumulate a bunch of stuff
that we don't need and bring it back to
our houses that are filled with more
stuff that we don't need so we all like
to do that
um we're all consumers
we watched too much TV we spend a lot of
time on the Internet
we love porn okay when I say we I'm
talking about general you know the
general American the average American
this describes that person
is that enough to make a country
that's enough to make a reddit community
okay that's enough to make a club
it's not enough to make a nation
especially not a nation that was
originally built upon ideals America is
unique or used to be because it has a
Creed it has an almost religious Creed
most countries don't have Creed's we do
most countries aren't founded that way
they're not founded with this
declaration of what we believe that's
how religions are founded our country
was founded like a religion and what is
our Creed we all should know the Creed
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men are created equal endowed by
their creator with certain inalienable
rights among these are life liberty
pursuit of happiness
and that to secure these rights
governments are instituted among men
deriving their just powers from the
consent of the governed this is our
Creed and it says that Americans believe
first in self-evident objective truth
Americans believe in a creator Americans
believe in the inherent dignity of human
beings Americans believe in the right to
life and the right to Liberty Liberty
Americans believe in the consent of the
governed
those are the six things
the six doctrinal points
that
are supposed to hold all Americans
together
now I ask you how many Americans believe
that all six anymore
how many believes in even one of them
and what happens to a nation founded on
a Creed
when half the country no longer believes
in the Creed what happens
you
you know I'm not imagining things and
neither are you
if you ever get the feeling that you no
longer even live in the same country as
your fellow Americans and when I look at
it I see that many Americans exist in a
place where there is no God there is no
such thing as man or woman there is no
truth there is no objective morality
babies aren't people marriage is nothing
but a societal construct the whole point
of life is to make money and to buy
things and to go on nice vacations and
the government's job is to take care of
us
that's the country that a lot of
Americans live in and I don't relate to
that country or to those people they're
foreign to me
I share nothing at all in common with
them you know forget about shared ideals
we don't even share a universe anymore
we don't even share a reality anymore we
cannot agree on even the most
fundamental definition of what reality
is okay that's how bad the division is
we can't even all agree that there is
such a thing as reality
there are a lot of us who think that we
could just make up reality as we go
along and that's why we're more divided
now than we were during the Civil War
more divided
I I've been studying the Civil War for a
long time it's been an interest of mine
and when you read about the Civil War
the thing that jumps out at you is that
yeah Americans were obviously deeply
divided not just over slavery but
culturally there was a deep cultural
division yet they still shared an
essential belief in God and in truth and
in virtue they still had that
they applied those beliefs differently
and they didn't include everyone in that
belief okay
both sides were filled with racists
let's be honest but they still had the
belief and that's why when you read you
know you read about these about these
stories from the civil war that seems so
strange so bizarre to us nowadays but
you read about these these incidents
where and it happened more than once
where the night before a big battle
you'd have the two sides on either end
of a battlefield and the night before
they would meet in the middle and
exchange you know they trade tobacco and
they talk and they maybe have share food
sometimes they would be dancing and all
this kind of stuff and then they'd go
back to their sides and kill each other
a few hours later
and that's what makes the Civil War such
a sad story aside from the 66 hundred
thousand people that died what makes it
so sad is that these were really
brothers these were brothers
it really was brother against brother
literally in some cases but but also in
the sense that these were countrymen
they were brothers they had this there
were certain ties that still bound them
together
and so you found there was this mutual
respect
yeah even while they were while they
were shooting at each other and stabbing
each other to death with bayonets and
expend and blowing each other apart with
cannonballs even in the midst of that
there was still this respect between the
two sides
there was more respect
I think on a Civil War battlefield then
there is now on Twitter
because now we don't have anything at
all in common we don't even have that
essential belief in God truth morality
virtue dignity we don't even have that
now we aren't shooting at each other
there's no civil war breaking out and I
think part of the reason for that is
that the divide is not exactly
Geographic and so it's hard for there to
be a civil war when everyone's kind of
intermingled with each other but second
I think people are also too lazy for a
civil war we wouldn't want to do
anything that would jeopardize our
ability to go home and watch Netflix at
night and that's the main thing that we
care about so really we're not shooting
each other because we're too lazy for
that and and we'd rather watch TV and
maybe that will be our saving grace and
that'll be the thing that that saves us
from a another gruesome war like the
Civil War but still the division is
there
hey listen I I know people will say oh
you're such a pessimist it isn't that
bad get out of your bubble go into the
real world get off the internet go meet
people people are fine in the real world
they get along fine you're basing all
this on the Internet's well let me say
two things in response to that number
one I live in the real world okay I'm
not in a bubble
travel the country and I meet thousands
of people every year
I'd probably build about I've been to
probably about 30 or 35 different states
in the last two years for speaking
events and yes people are basically
polite to one another we basically get
along okay for the most part
there isn't chaos in the streets most of
the time although sometimes there is but
the problem is I could travel anywhere
in the world and it would be the same I
might avoid a place like Syria but if I
went to France or China or Thailand or
Australia or Mexico I could walk by
people on the street and say hello and
they would say hello and we'd be
friendly to each other
I could make Pleasant small talk if I
knew the language anyway and people
would be basically you know nice to each
other
well that's not enough to make us
countrymen
to be my countryman there needs to be
something deeper holding us together
than just mere niceties and small talk
and pleasantries
and I wouldn't have that deeper thing
tying me to somebody in China or France
and I don't have it here anymore
the second thing just just quickly the
Internet is the real world okay
I hate this thing that people do where
they say ah you know people are nasty to
each other on the internet but not in
the real world what do you think the
Internet is do you think this is a dream
you think this is a hallucination no
this is real this is a real tool whereby
real humans communicate with other real
humans so if you're a terrible monstrous
jerk on the internet that means that
you're a terrible monstrous jerk in
general that's the kind of person you
are and if it seems like there are a lot
of bad people on the internet that's
because there are a lot of bad people in
the world the fact that they're you know
that they that they save all their
badness for the Internet's then they go
out and act nice in the real world that
just proves that they're cowards it
doesn't prove anything else other than
that
so yes I think I think that
even the Internet is indicative of the
divisions that exist in our country
and now is the part I know where I'm
supposed to offer an answer
people get angry when we talk about
these things and and they say oh you
know what are your solutions don't just
point out the bad things offer solutions
well I'm sorry I don't have a five-step
solution I don't have a five-step plan
for how to solve our societal implosion
okay I don't have that
is it even possible for a civilization
to pull itself back from the brink is it
possible for it to go right up to the
edge of destruction and then pull a
u-turn and go back the other way I you
know as any civilization in history ever
done that before the Romans couldn't
pull it off
the Mayans couldn't the Mesopotamians I
mean could we be the first ones ever to
do that
we can hope so
but that certainly won't happen if we
refuse to face the reality
of our current situation
the more that we cling to these silly
slogans that nobody really believes
Americans love freedom Americans love
equality as long as we cling to that
there's no hope for us
because that means we're just gonna skip
you know we're just gonna hold hands and
skip right into oblivion
if there is any way to stop this it has
to start with accepting the reality of
the situation acceptance is the right is
the first step right and then once we've
accepted it
what's next
pray
the next step is to pray if there's any
chance at a national revival it's only
gonna happen with God's blessing God
will decide and if God looks at our
country and says nope you guys had your
chance you screwed it up and now you're
gonna reap what you sow if he says that
then that's it it's over the judgment
has been made
but we could pray to God and beg for
another chance beg for him to allow us
to turn things around I don't think we'd
deserve that we deserve to fall apart we
do but
we can beg for what we don't deserve
so do that
and tend to your family hold your
children close I don't know if we can
save the entire country from collapse
but I do know we can save our own
families and we have to focus on that
now
we have to focus on shielding our
children from the debris if everything
does start falling apart
and beyond that be vigilance
because I do believe that there are
tough times ahead I don't know what
those tough times will look like exactly
but
I do believe they're coming
so be vigilant and short pray for a
miracle because a miracle is what it's
going to take
but while you're praying for the miracle
and hoping for the miracle maybe in the
meantime buy yourself a gun
just in case
alright that's it for me have a great
day everyone Godspeed